qui se passe
Daniel c'est un grand jour aujourd'hui
pour toi ouis ah oui puisque Daniel
c'est son anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
app c'est l'anniversaire de
Dani
Dani 60 ans selon les syndicats 120
selon la
police température ressentie 122
température réelle 60 elle a 60 ans ma
Daniel ça y est mais s rol mais tu fou
parce que tu sais que l'avantage que tu
as toi tu es comme le commandant
coustaudou il a toujours fait vieux non
mais sans déconner donc en fait toi
quand on dit 60 ans frère tout le monde
m'a dit aujourd'hui j'ai dit Daniel Mor
à la 60 ans m'a fait
quoi 600 ans non frérot c'est un truc de
ouf c'estàd que quand tu fais vieux
jeune et ben en fait et ben elle est
tranquille le commandant con on l'a
jamais vu vous rappelez du commandant
coustud bien sûr bah le commandant
coustud j'ai jamais vu une ttée du
commandant coustud jeune il a toujours
été à 25 ans il avait un bonnet avec une
be bar blanche non mais sans déconner
bah toi c'est exactement pareil en fait
toi en fait tu avais la même teté à 25
ans on aurait dit la merre de mes
copines non mais sans déconner mais
c'est vrai je te jure que c'est vrai et
Daniel tu sais comme je t'aime je t'ai
d'ailleurs appelé à la radio aujourd'hui
avecou ça m'a fait ça m'a touché
vraiment ouaisie d'avant qu'on appelle
Sophie
di Sophie d'avant que
j'embrasse
Daniel j'ai un très beau cadeau pour
toi je vais te demander de de me
rejoindre au centre du plateau est-ce pe
amener une chaise s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
merci
tu t'attendais pas à ça c'est un cadeau
en deux temps pour toi Daniel a eu un
grand amour dans sa vie non c'était le
beau jean le beau jean le Poulin ah Jean
Le Poulin ah oui ah le beau le beau jean
lepoulin est-ce qu'on peut rettre une
photo de Jean lepoulin juste une photo
s'il vous plaît de Jean lepoulin
avantage quand Mme le prof d' école
exactement Jean lepoulin ah non il est
pas mal voilà c'est vrai c'est vrai que
cette photo est de ses plus B il est
magnifique
c'est incroyable moi j'adore écoutez je
trouve je le trouve magnifique et Daniel
Daniel comme je te
[Rires]
comprendsavir d'avoir eu comme premier
amour ce beau jean leouin non
franchement che lui et la cravate lui va
à merveille tout c'estes mains ses yeux
ses
yeux super comédi c'est vrai c'est pas
nul c'est pas nul non mais c'est un
super
Comé écoute-moi bien franchement ton
cadeau il est incroyable parce que Jean
une réplique non il est pas là Jean non
non Jean est là et il t'a laissé un
message
[Musique]
regarde bonjour ma petite chudir adoré
c'est Jean lepoulin ton jeano
aujourd'hui c'est le jour des mors mais
pas que puisque c'est ton anniversaire
alors joyeux anniversaire et à très
bientôt làhaut mais en attendant j'ai
une surprise pour toi alors ouvre bien
tes yeux et retire ta
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
culotte
le poul le poul le poul le poul le pou
le pou
le le pou le
[Applaudissements]
pou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bra Ahou quand Mme ah
ouaisas-y leou leouin leoulin
leoulin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le poul le pou le pou le chou le poul le
[Applaudissements]
chouou
leou le
Bou le Bou le poula le Bou le Bou le Bou
le Bou le Bou le Bou leou le
[Applaudissements]
boul
[Musique]
mercici
merci
merci le Poulin merci merci bravo
bravo tu
vois tu crois pas je vois pas comme
ça
franchement pas pour je voyais pas comme
ça ce gen le Poulin non mais c'est
incroyable il est incroyable non mais
franchement j'adore le Poulin CIT
impressionnant ah ouais j'avais son
regard là c'était impressionn en paséit
son
regard tu as kiffé tu as kiffé ah ouais
non mais franchement ass quand il parle
de moi là et tout qu'est-ce que tu fais
ce soir souff jeis le concert d'
dueille
la guitare de bois prendre un enfant par
la
main et l'emmener vers demain non mais
attends c'est pas vrai tu VO F bergère
il fait 50 ans de carrière je serai un
petit peu en retard mais j'y vais
j'espère tu vas pas rater les tubes
quand même non mais sans déconner des
tubes non mais tu vas voir le concert
div donc ton anniversaire c'est ça c'est
ça coput-re que tu pourrais retrouver
Gess ton anniversaire tu vas voir toute
seule le concert div du tu sais que j'ai
deux potes qui viennent après l'émission
tu veux pas venir dîner avec nous bah
c'est mieux ah bah oui fa voir bon jeai
même je l'ai déjà vu
du prendre un enfant par la main bah
mais tu es là et l'emmener vers demain
tu m'aurais dit je serais venu j'adore
ah ou ah ben non non je rigolais euh non
en c'est c'est sérieux vous l'emenez
pour regarde le début c'est comme
ça l'intro est très longue
[Musique]
ouais c'est VI qu' fait c'est qui fait
ça bien c'est maxi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention l'ro est très
[Applaudissements]
long on croit qu'ils ont mis l'instru
mais non elle est très longue non non
elle est très longue non non elle est
trs long ça je la connais regarde ça là
attention
attention att attention attention voilà
il va finir il va finir ça et après en
fait il a fait toute la chanson d'instru
et après il chant tu vas voir j'ai
compris le V ça va être maintenant
attention prendre un enfant par la
[Musique]
main et l'emmener vers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
demain don la confiance en son prendre
un enfant par le roi est magnifique
prendre un enfant
dans et pour la première fois
j'adore sécher ces en
étouf ah de Jo prendre un
enfant tu vas kiffer ce
soir par contre
attention un concert à ne pas mettre
entre toutes les mains si vous êtes un
petit peu on rassera en ce moment là tu
vas voir là c'est mais j'adore il du MO
le petit pont de bois et tout ça c'est
pas il Bou le petit pont de bois c'est
vrai que ça
bougeera on peut pas le mettre le petit
pont de bois parce que quand il chant
quand il chante le petit pont de bois ça
il faut que vous sachiez c'est le climax
dans le concert les gars ils prennent
les
[Musique]
fauteuil les G g les G au concert sont
en c'est un truc de ouf mer il fait ses
50 ans de carrière ans mais ça il a une
meuf du taille ah oui là là sa femme
alors là c'est tellement belle histoire
moi ce je propose c'est que elle fait
son petit concert puis après vous venez
la chercher en en fin de concert pour
passer la fin de soirée avec elle et vos
COP je suis puni
moi qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il a rien fa
je suis puni
moi j'ai fait quoi moi j'ai fait quoi
allez sinon demain soir demain c'est
l'anniversaire de de Jean oui c'est
demain j appar apparemment il ilamb bah
il va venir avec moi il vous arrive du
NON NON t'enmerde pas t'enmerde pas
merci on se retrouve dans un instant à
tout de
suite